the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers but come on you know you've
already seen this movie
from the company that owns everything
you know and love and Diet spielberg
comes a movie that had to satisfy
decades of pent-up nerd expectations
make up for the prequels introduce the
franchise to a new generation of fans
make enough money to justify Disney's
four billion dollar investments and also
you know be good so no pressure Star
Wars The Force awakens the force has
awakened and its first order is to
revitalize the franchise while setting
the stage for an amazing expansion of
the Star Wars Cinematic Universe by
shamelessly remaking a new hope
let the who are you I'm the original
honest trailer voice and the originals
are always better yeah you wish now pipe
down I've got the best movie of the year
to talk about best oh man I'm not going
anywhere someone has to stop you from
going full fanboy oh I've got a bad
feeling about this all your favorite
characters are back for another
adventure Leia Chewie Han and they all
look really old
okay but these living legends are
passing the torch to a new generation of
Heroes like Rey an orphan scavenger
who's so poor she has to make her own
Star Wars action figures
she's a multilingual expert mechanic
slash ace pilot slash force using badass
who's so good at everything it makes her
character completely uncompelled how
dare you I mean come on how is she so
good at everything because you know she
has the force and it's awakening and the
force makes you awesome that's not how
the force works
shut up Han so calm but Ray's not the
only one obsessed with Star Wars meet
kylo Ren a brooding Jedi Outcast
torn between his family legacy and the
dark side never before has Star Wars had
a villain so layered so complex and so
whiny he acts like a goth kid who can't
find his eyeliner you know what if
you're gonna keep butting in why don't
you just take over now we're talking
gear up for if
so desperate to recapture the magic of
the first Star Wars it practically is
the first Star Wars featuring the desert
orphan finding a keloid with top-secret
information who escapes the Empire
thanks to the Millennium Falcon visits a
shady Cantina learns about the force
from a tiny alien watches a man in black
kill her mentor then help destroy a
Death Star by deactivating a shield
generator so that x-wings can make a
trench run it's another Death Star oh
man but it's so much more than a rehash
of everything that made a new hope great
it's got all new stories to tell like
Finn a conflicted first order
stormtrooper turned rebel hunky badass
poe dameron and don't forget Captain
phasma an awesome looking stormtrooper
commander who is completely wasted in
just 91 seconds of screen time that end
with her useless character getting
thrown in the garbage yeah they totally
wasted Brina ptarth but get ready to
speculate as Abrams plants the seeds of
questions that will drive fans wild with
anticipation like who is Snoke who are
Rey's parents and why does r2d2 suddenly
wake up plus questions that will annoy
the rest of the fans like why does r2d2
suddenly wake up why is everyone in the
galaxy either a Skywalker or a solo and
why would we expect the guy who made
laws to have good answers for any of
these questions
where'd you get that a good question for
another time man is there anything we
can agree on about this movie I don't
know how about on the count of three we
name our favorite parts ready
one two three kylo ren's dr. blaster
bolt flanker crash our destroyer Poe
dameron's beautiful face and lap bar
okay now Lee's favorite we're hugging
rating the computer on solid ice did we
just become best friends yes story
lei AARP bear race ooh better Anakin
fn-2187 hey
as my pin number on polo emperor
baltimore r2d2 to han solo a waste of
the perfectly good the raid cast the
easiest money Mark Hamill ever made and
butthole eyes star wars a familiar hope
well nice meeting you other epic voice
guy may the voice be with you hey guys
any reason why you didn't invite me who
are you
i the first ever honest trailer remember
in 3d hey guys don't forget about me I
did avatar oh man I love how you said
bloob bloob bloob please lose believes
her gar ZAR her through were having a
voice party how'd you all get in here I
got some pizza rolls in my underwear if
you want some maybe you should consider
locking your booth be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers hey screen
junkies now that the force is with us
again it's time for another awakening
we've teamed up with the awesome team
from how it should have ended for an
exclusive brand-new show after credits
where we give our favorite movies the
after credits scenes they deserve click
the box to watch the first episode for
interstellar right now will drop for new
episodes each and every month
exclusively on screen junkies plus so
crack open the bookcase and watch our
first episode right now Merve boobs like
you said it in Game of Thrones honest
trailer welcome aboard the SS boaty
mcboatface
hi I'm negan
Luke I am NOT your father I am a potato
honey where are my pants M night
Shyamalan is the best director to ever
live Oh
my name is crap bag first name crap last
name bag full of a tube winner is coming
and do star was the force awakens we
just did